ماندو استحواذه على تويتر يؤكد الى الماسك
انه اشترى تويتر لانه يعتبره الساحه
الرقميه العامه للديمقراطيه وان ضبط
المحتوى امر مقيد جدا لكن رؤيته لحريه
التعبير تثير مخاوف من زياده الاساءات على
المنصه ماسكه طرف بان انطباعات خطاب
الكراهيه ارتفعت فعلا لكنه اعتبر ان
الاعداد المذكوره للتغريدات المسيئه مضلله
مصر قال ان العصفور تحرر فرد عليه المفوض
الاوروبي للسوق الداخليه تيري بريتون ان
العصفوره الذي تحرر سيطير بحسب قواعدنا
الاوروبيه وهدده بالغرامه والاغلاق قبل
هاكان ماسك اصدر عفوا واسعا عن معظم
الحسابات المحظوره منها حساب الرئيس
السابق ترامب لكن على الجانب الاخر علق
ملكه حساب المغني الشهير كان ويست
لانتهاكه قانونا ضد التحريض على العنف
وكذلك اكد انه لن يعيد تفعيل حساب صاحب
نظريه المؤامره الامريكيه اليميني المتطرف
اليكس جونس واخيرا السؤال المطروح هو اذا
كانت قرارات ماسك مرفوضه فلماذا اذا كلما
طرح استفتاء ان على صفحته تاتي النتيجه
لصالحه غالبا